[Music]
happy Sunday you guys are a Saturday if
you're one of our patrons and gets to
see this [ __ ] early this is matinee 78
yeah um we did let's see we did to
Netflix and two and one shutter yeah
what were they Mary Ann Tiger King so
yeah
that'll probably be a long segment okay
but yeah so two of these are actually
series and one of them is a movie so the
first one that I watched was Mary Ann
now this actually came out it dropped on
Netflix back in September mid September
of 2019 and there was a lot of buzz
about it like on you know different
horror sites and stuff like that and
people kept like recommending it to me
and I kept saying I'll get around to it
I'll get around to it I'll get around to
it and finally finally now this many
months later I finally got around to
watching it I guess because I it's
harder for me to like watch a series
because I know I'll get like involved
and then I'll have to like watch it over
successive nights and it's like a big
time commitment so sometimes I'll put
off series like longer than I would a
movie which you know is over an hour and
half or whatever because this is an
eighth episode French horror series each
episodes about an hour long so it's
about an eight hour watch I watched it
over two nights
this was actually [ __ ] excellent and
it seems like a lot of reviewers like
said the same thing unfortunately for
whatever reason even though it seemed to
have like a lot of good buzz about it
it's not getting a second season even
though they didn't leave they left a
little bit of a cliffhanger you know I'm
not gonna spoil anything if you haven't
seen it yet but they did leave it you
know they wrapped up most most things
but they did leave it open you know for
a second season you know if they wanted
to go in that direction and I was kind
of interested to see what was gonna
happen with that but I guess we can't
have everything I guess I'm not gonna
get it because apparently they're not
making another one I thought it looked
well made and I did see some special
effects stuff but it really didn't get
me interested it couldn't get me out of
my damn tablet he's always there
I look up every now and then yeah my god
yeah but then I'd look I'm glad yeah it
looks pretty cool I
yeah I just it wasn't for me you know
most of the effects in this and I feel
like a lot of people will probably
compare it to haunting of Hill House and
I can see why you would in the sense
that this uses like very effectively
relies more on kind of like unsettling
imagery rather than say jump scares and
stuff but totally it's honestly this is
kind of more like it was very Stephen
King it had a very Stephen King kind of
vibe had a little bit of it going on in
there like some other [ __ ] like that's
not exactly like that but and I guess
because it was set like in like a small
coastal town in France called Eldon so
it had that kind of that kind of feel to
it you know what I mean with that kind
of Stephen King small town main type of
thing going on and someone go having to
go back to their hometown where they
haven't been for a long time to like
fight an evil that has returned so it
kind of had that sort of vibe to it so
in that way and I know this is gonna be
like a bold statement cuz I love
taunting of Hill House I actually liked
this slightly better I thought this was
paced a bit better it's like it wasn't
quite as slow um you know what I mean
and I don't have a problem with that
generally like you know and I like I
said I love taunting of Hill House so
don't get that you know and but like I
said these are very different another
way that I think this was kind of more
Stephen King like was that they they
very effectively threaded some humor in
there it's not like zany or wacky like
over-the-top humor um most of the humor
comes from inspector ronan like this
kind of really weird like inspector
character but i loved him he was [ __ ]
great so I think they really
successfully kind of matched all these
things together with like humor and
horror and I think it was like largely
successful so the story basically is
that there's this girl named Emma and
Emma Larsa mom and she is like a very
famous horror writer and her most famous
series has been you know this series
about a demon or a witch or something
like that named Mary Ann and she has
invented this kind of like paranormal
investigator character that fights her
now at the beginning of
the series she has decided she doesn't
really want to want to write horror
anymore and so she kills off her main
character and at this point [ __ ] starts
to get really weird like this person
turns up that was a friend of hers like
from a long time ago over the old home
town and brings her some very unusual
things and is telling her that she has
to go back home or like all this bad
[ __ ] is gonna happen
so as it goes on like I said I'm gonna
not spoil it because I really think
people should watch this because it's
really really good but she basically has
to go back to this shitty town that she
thought that she would never go to it's
not a shitty town but she you know she
left it when she was a kid and she has
to go back to this town and kind of like
fight this evil that has returned and
there's like a reason why it has come
back and all this other kind of stuff so
it kind of goes along that route she
kind of like reconnects with a lot of
her you know old friends were all grown
up now and you know has to fight this
thing that has you know come back for
them and is threatening you know people
and her family and her friends and
things like that
now one thing I will say about this that
this I believe I'm not entirely certain
but some of the other reviews I saw this
said that this was largely practical
effects like a lot of the kind of demon
stuff and like the stuff in her
nightmares and all that kind of stuff I
believe most of it was done with
puppetry with just a little bit of CGI
sprinkled on top and it was so it looked
really good and there's like some really
I mean some of it obviously was CGI like
with some of the demonic effects like
with the mouth stretching and you know
the glowing eyes and stuff like that
that was CGI but I think that most of
the demon stuff was puppets and they
really really look cool I will say that
this series even from like the first
episode had some of the most unsettling
imagery that I've ever seen like in a
horror series it was scarier than
haunting of Hill House I thought just
because and a lot of it comes from like
not monsters or jump scares and there's
a couple of jump scares but not really
it's mostly the first two or three
episodes particularly there's this one
woman in there
Madame Dosher on and she is hosting like
Mary Ann I guess you want if you want to
say that this woman I don't know if they
did something to her face like with
makeup or with CGI or something like
that but this is the freakiest [ __ ]
looking woman like the expressions she
makes and all this other case and it
doesn't look like they did anything
weird to her face it just looks like
she's really really good at making these
really really unsettling expressions
that really make you so I think like the
first part of it where she's in it
because she's in it through the whole
thing but it's like you know there's a
lot of her like in the first two or
three episodes and she's great she is
like [ __ ] dynamite she's super super
[ __ ] creepy and just these creepy
[ __ ] expressions that she makes I
also love a lot of the demon faces which
you kind of see just very briefly are
really really creepy really unsettling
there's this one great scene I think
it's might be in the first episode where
and this actually really kind of freaked
me out because this [ __ ] kind of freaks
me out cuz I have nightmares like this
but where she's like laying in bed next
to her boyfriend and she wakes up or she
thinks she wakes up and he's like turns
back to order because you know he's mad
at her because she went out and got
drunk when they were supposed to go do
something and so he says she says to him
because they're fighting just like oh
well you know turn around and he says
very creepily are you sure you want me
to turn bad and then like when he turns
around asleep is just really really
creepy yeah I loved it I thought it was
really really good
you know it came out a while back so I
and I know like some of you have seen it
because I know some of you have
recommended it some and stuff if you
like haunting of Hill House if you've
liked it if you like like Stephen King
type stuff I think you'll really dig
this yes it's in French you can watch it
dubbed I've heard mixed reviews of the
dubbing I do not like dubbing so I never
watch it some people said the English
dub was really good and like not
noticeable some people said the English
dub was terrible so I don't know your
mileage may vary if you don't mind
dubbing than watch it dubbed but I watch
it it's subtitled knows much better the
reason why I didn't like it is a early
on in the series they didn't seem to
really make an attempt to get you into
the characters at all from my point of
view guys
thought the characters are kind of bland
and uninteresting it looked like it got
better as it unfolded but it it happened
a little too late for me you know what I
mean
it's serious has to catch me early you
know time it's like 10 15 20 minutes to
me it just kind of had that kind of
European stale feeling to me they didn't
get that at all I got it well I was
looking up later it looked like it got a
little bit better but it started off on
the wrong foot for me I didn't really
care about the main characters now I
will say that the main character she
comes off initially as a little bit
unlikable yeah but but as the as it goes
on there's a reason why she's like that
and it ties in directly like with the
plot and what's going on with the story
and you come to like sympathize more and
more with her and I actually really
liked the woman that played her
assistant Camille I really liked her so
I think it was good that they paired
those two up because Camille was a lot
more was a lot more likeable a lot more
sympathetic character so they paired
those two up so if you didn't like Emma
then you like there was someone else
there that you could relate to you feel
sorry for I did like Emma because you
know like I said even though she can't
came off as a little unlikable you could
tell that there was a reason why that
would probably work in a book but to me
it doesn't work in a movie or a series
you know I mean because I don't think it
makes it good I think I just think it
was a you know maybe maybe you know
artistically when it comes to writing
that might have been a proper a good
decision but it's in terms of an
entertainment I think it's a poor
decision you want you want the
characters to be likeable and you want
to bring the audience in very early so
you can keep them you know if I don't
like it within 10 or 15 20 minutes I
alternate I lose all interest and it's
kind of like it leaves a bad impression
and it doesn't ever really recover no
just you know tell the truth yeah well
like I said I really love this and it
seemed like most people that watched it
really loved it you know so if you
haven't seen it definitely check it out
like I said I tried not to spoil
anything um but you know if you if you
don't mind like European horror and
stuff like that like I said if you liked
haunting of Hill House you probably dig
this as well it's actually a bit faster
paced and has like more [ __ ] going on
it's not getting renewed
so maybe a lot of people felt the way I
did you know I mean well like I said all
the people that watched it and went
through the whole thing liked it but I
must have not been successful with the
market because it turned him off for
early maybe or I'm like I said there
could be a million other reason could be
why it wasn't good um but bland and
uninteresting for a foot for that first
20-30 minutes now this is just checked
out yeah well I didn't get that
impression yeah your mileage may vary
like it's on the proof but if you like
horror and if you like horror series and
it sounds like something you would dig
then definitely check it out it's still
there on Netflix if you want to watch it
if you got an eight hour time commitment
then you know probably most people do
because they're sitting at home right
now if you want them to watch then check
it out
you
so finally which you've all been waiting
for we've been hinting around at like
watching this on the sidetrack show but
now we can give it our full and
undivided attention this is the
batshit-crazy that is known as tiger
king original Netflix series I'm so glad
that I watched this series it was very
educational was you know media brought
me to a new level of understanding you
know watching this [ __ ] how [ __ ] up
some people can be I mean these people
were [ __ ] up yeah and uh it was
hilarious Matt now it's not hilarious
it's not hilarious it's ridiculous yeah
yeah that's what it is this is the this
one's like required viewing you have to
see this yeah I mean and I feel like
every review I've read of it is like
pretty much says the same thing that's
that it's just like this is the craziest
yeah you will ever watch you have to see
this it's really there's so much oh that
does not make [ __ ] sense people that
don't make sense groups of people that
don't make sense doing things that don't
make sense making videos that don't make
videos it deliberately unbelievable that
are here unbelievable you'll have a
person who has so many different
clashing and and contradiction to
contradict contradicting [ __ ]
elements to that person you're like how
could that be happening in one place one
person I don't understand I just you
know what I wasn't fake [ __ ] was real no
that's what I mean that you don't get
the sense that these are like people
that are playing it up for the camera or
anything of that nature these are like
the way that these people really are and
it happens like even in the first 10
minutes I think you know what cuz I had
been watching the end of Mary Ann and
then we started watching this one we
watched the first episode and within the
first five minutes I said to him because
he was like in the bathroom I said I
already love this I already love this
like in the first five minutes I said I
can already tell this is gonna be the
most units
this [ __ ] Looney Tunes [ __ ] show
it's like it's it's it's I don't want to
say that it's like just oh it's so crazy
and wacky and everything like that it is
it's like entertaining but it's also one
of those things where it's very real and
it's also kind of tragic and then you
feel bad for watching it you know I mean
it's like that yeah but yeah and you
know this is something where it's very
difficult to review this without
spoiling some of the [ __ ] greatest
elements of this reality series you just
have to let it unfold because you're
introduced into you're in this series
introduces you to a scene and a group of
people in a scene and it it doesn't tell
you everything at you know all at once
yeah it's so nothing well yeah and then
you realize how wrong you were
and as you watch it yeah so you form
these opinions and then oh like a the
episodes later you're like wait a minute
hold on we'll see this is why whatever
form opinions everywhere you have all
the information you have all because you
never know where the [ __ ] is going and
like I said I I believe that this
documentary was filmed over a five-year
period yeah so some of the stuff that
unfolded unfolded like in real time like
while the documentary makers were making
it and they must have just been like
bitching you know what I mean like as
this gut cuz it just gets more and more
batshit [ __ ] Christ as time goes awry
see enough to where people actually get
killed and people actually go to prison
that's how [ __ ] crazy this [ __ ] is
and not even it's like even the craziest
[ __ ] on there is like stuff that doesn't
even I don't even know it's like stuff
that doesn't even result in anyone dying
or anyone going to jail or anything like
that just some of the most what the [ __ ]
moments in the you know and there's just
one the foot one one - [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] moment have another yeah now a lot
of this takes place in Florida well
Oklahoma most of it takes place well
what about all the [ __ ] all those all
those little tiger farms were in
Oklahoma Joe exotics was yeah well the
main one but the other ones
they were in Florida weren't they yeah
um yeah be Carroll's was in Tampa Tampa
maybe I thought yeah but yeah Joe
exactly that man guy his is Tony Montana
the [ __ ] drug dealer wasn't that was
Miami Miami all right and then the other
guy with the damn harem of women was
floor cantle that I don't know if that
was Florida or I thought might have been
somewhere else okay I can trim it look
like Florida from the turret maybe but I
don't I don't the trees and [ __ ] so you
know but it's just
I thought the horse scene was bad my
[ __ ] family is involved with the
English a question horse seen since I
was a little kid and weird [ __ ] happens
in [ __ ] dudes at on barns and
trainers and [ __ ] girls that ride
horses and the [ __ ] weird [ __ ] that
they do now if a girl likes horses and
she's got ponies as [ __ ] don't trust her
can't trust her [ __ ] and if a dude is
a trainer be careful around that dude
and all those women all right it's it's
just this [ __ ] weird thing that
happens and the [ __ ] horse well I
thought the horse scene was bad yeah you
thought that was crazy the [ __ ] big
cat seems like on steroids
every single person it just is a lunatic
it attracts lunatics every single a
really different and entertaining ways
yeah and sometimes murderous ways yeah
but they're all lunatics lunatics yeah
it's just I mean okay now are times
horses of 14th whatever no lunatic I
mean obviously this is based on a true
story and they've already done like Joe
exotic who's kind of the main character
oh there's lots of other characters kind
of swirling around him but um a lot of
people knew him they've done like a
whole six-part podcast series on him he
did he was in like The New Yorker like
they did a big thing about him back then
and most and a lot of people heard of
him because he ran for president back in
2016 and then he ran for governor and
his campaign was so hilarious like all
his campaign videos and stuff like that
that I think they showed him like on the
daily show and stuff like that so he
kind of got a national platform around
then
as being like this crazy character but I
don't think people realize the extent to
which [ __ ] was going on behind the
scenes it's like and it's really sad
because I don't know it's like I don't
really want to this is one of those
things where this series there are
really no heroes I mean other than you
know a lot of the employees of Joe
exotic and a lot of the employees of
other you know the other people that
around the periphery a lot of them
seemed like perfectly nice normal people
generally but all of the main players in
this [ __ ] crazy are crazy and I think
some of them might be criminals um well
some of them definitely are criminals
yeah some of them just allegedly are
criminals but they don't have any proof
and stuff like that so it's really hard
to you know I have my own ideas about
some stuff that happened during a lot of
this fiasco if we call it that but I you
know I don't really want to say because
you know sometimes there's no proof
either way like some people probably
should be in jail that are not in jail
no we're saying criminals we're not
talking about like a [ __ ] Ronald
McDonald type burglar Hamburglar a
stereotypical running around they're not
like that they're just [ __ ] they have
no problem with breaking rules and
regulations they have no problems with
[ __ ] [ __ ] that would [ __ ] get you
twenty thirty years in prison they just
do it yeah and they don't even think
it's wrong yeah these are almost because
I feel like especially if you're going
to maybe the reason that this that the
big cat business for what if you know
for lack of a better - yeah and there's
not supposed to be a big cat yes you're
like okay sell any of that [ __ ] it's
technically illegal right um you know
you can't like by trade them you're you
know you can't sell the the babies you
can't you can't you can't do anything
like that because they're doing all that
actually yeah cuz I saw damn lion skin I
saw a lion skin in the background of
that debt
guys trailer yeah get a [ __ ] lion
skin you know yeah lions were dying off
of that and that Farley just had 200 of
them of course some of them are gonna
die every now and then to old age
disease or whatever yeah but he had that
[ __ ] lion skin sitting back back
there which immediately I thought I
immediately thought I bet you their skin
in those lines that they died selling
that [ __ ] it wouldn't surprise me I mean
you know allegedly it wouldn't surprise
me a lot of things because a lot of poor
Vista yeah a lot of people that worked
for them um you know later on they would
say stuff you know they were you know
killing well like once the baby's got
like past the stage where they could
charge people to come and pet them and
stuff like that which is also illegal
yeah um that they were gassing them and
stuff and it just seems like really sad
because what got lost in all of this was
the cats it does seem like at least Joe
exotic and probably some apart Carroll
Baskin and stuff like that it does seem
like initially their intentions were
good yeah none of these people's
intentions were good but I don't well I
don't think that it ended up that way
like I do think that he started out I
mean he was always been like kind of a
crazy character but I do think that at
first he generally genuinely did care
for the cats but I think as he got nutty
or nuttier a lot of money to keep
something like that roll roll yeah so
you have to start doing crooked [ __ ] in
order to get the money - yeah he could
dam Tigers so there's all kind of and
then to pay the employees and a lot of
them didn't like they were getting paid
and it wasn't just his place there all
the other tiger places were like that
too it
I ain't it up getting kind of torn
because you know I kinda I have a
[ __ ] agricultural background when it
comes to horses and [ __ ] in agricultural
but you know farming type background
when it comes to horses and stuff people
always said you gotta let those horses
go you got the horse go they all died
alright there's their habitats pretty
much gone
they were selectively bred to be you
know ridden and to work horses if you
let a course go he just comes right back
to the stall yeah at this point they're
2ms their domestic just like let that
cat go let that dog go dad just come
right back home so you have to take care
of the horses you're you're a custodian
of the
existence well that's kind of the way
these Tigers are now because there are
more tigers in captivity in places like
this then there are out the wild if you
let them go they'll all die because
there's not enough the land can't bear
them there isn't enough food out for
them so they hunt their prey to
extinction because they're not all on
there now in Africa on a little small
and Asia and little small plots of land
so that land can't support the tiger
population that you have it can only
support the wild one the wild ones
which is about I think it's about half
of what I believe it is I think there's
only 5,000 tigers left in the wild right
I'm not sure about other ones so if you
want Tigers in the damn future if you
care about tires that means you have to
have a breeding population raised in
captivity to ensure the survival that
species because it's gonna go extinct
which I don't have a problem with that
at all but don't let these jokers do it
but here's the weird thing all the
[ __ ] zoos who League who take care of
them the right way are buying them from
these guys even though they're hiding
that fact but that's where the zoos are
get them yeah so the whole it's a whole
gray world of [ __ ] dealing with these
Tigers the only way these tigers and
lions are gonna survive long term is if
they can somehow survive
the way house cats and dogs have to
where they start to evolve alongside man
that's the only way they're gonna make
it they're gonna make it in man's
custody but you don't want these dudes
doing it that's what I mean they're that
only dudes doing it though yeah it's
like that's why I don't have a problem
at all with having regulations on this
kind of [ __ ] because you just don't want
some crazy hillbilly like essentially
out in Oklahoma I love them with the
regulations is is that administration's
change out and eventually you get a
lunatics in the government who will
regulate something like this out of
existence based on [ __ ] they know
nothing about ok the oval we can't do
that well the next thing you know all
the breeders are gone and then the
Tigers disappear and the Tigers are not
extinct yeah because you're trying to
protect the tiger and then the tiger
goes extinct like I said I think that
there particularly if an animal is
endangered yes there should be a
breeding program and if you have to keep
them in captivity for X amount of time
but like I said I don't think that there
I don't think there should be any
controversy
about just not letting any any old dude
lunatic like raise them like in his
backyard and it seems to be only
lunatics are interested in these things
which that's weird
well at least on this show on it yeah
they're all they're all like there's a
dude here live down here used to be one
of the Tarzan's I don't know if he's
still alive but he was an old man last I
heard about him he had a bunch of lions
but they were in his private collection
you know of lions and they lived in a
damn house with him there's all these
farms in Florida
we're didn't get three or four that's
some weird [ __ ] yeah but you know he
raised him kind of like house cats now
they all claim that they're rescues oh
well they're rescued all right rescued
from these dudes right here then for
money that's how they rescued him Jiri
yeah because there's a whole black mark
as a whole black our case because
obviously people that want them are
gonna get them you know and they have to
get to black market nowadays because
it's not legal to sell or trade them and
contrary to what people believe you know
in some countries you can keep them as
pets you know fishing in the Middle East
you know rich people own them as pets
they make a good pet they're a social
animal well depending on how early you
get yeah they'll bomb the human know
just and they're like they're a social
animal they're kind of like having a big
dog but the problem is is that every now
and then if you try to play with your
cat you can't combine hurt you I've been
you know bitten by one of my cats it was
an accident though yeah I was trying to
again one of these things goes off on
you man they weigh 400 [ __ ] pounds
it's like a huge claws a huge teeth that
bite right through you and it happens
and it shows it in this you know I mean
word and I think it's the first episode
yeah and he just walked in one time a
little bit of perfume that fell on his
damn shoe and [ __ ] lion tried to take
the shoe off his foot I started to try
hit it was in it was a boot you couldn't
get you off so you know yet to see how
that [ __ ] goes you know it's just
misunderstandings could happen they
they're powerful animals yeah they're
very large and they can use you in a
heartbeat
yeah and they might like you but then
the next thing one thing leads to
another and they've just they're killing
you that's what I mean you get on their
wrong side one day
you don't know like you know just a
little bitty cat yeah you know they'll
turn on you and scratch your second then
they forget about it yeah but you know
if that happens with a lion or a tiger
your dad so you can't it'll eat your
face you can't make any mistakes with
him yeah and it really does seem to me
that you know particularly with Joe
exotics thing and you know mainly
because that's kind of what this focuses
on I mean he hired ex-cons which is fine
most of them seem like perfectly lovely
people yeah most of new thing wrong um
but he also has those ex-cons who run
around guns - yeah didn't even say
anything about that cuz they had to have
guns for security people were breaking
in and harassing the [ __ ] and [ __ ]
next thing you know a tiger could turn
on you yeah I might have to shoot a tag
yeah though they didn't want to admit it
but they show him using he doesn't shoot
the tiger or that it was a lion actually
didn't shoot the lion but he shoots at
the lion to get the lion to [ __ ] it let
go let go of him but yeah they never
really mentioned that that there are a
lot of felons running around guns in
holsters yeah I'm not sure what the laws
are in Oklahoma well the federal laws
and state laws it just it just depends
on whether or not you're considered a
felon at the time yeah cuz some of them
I don't really know what they did they
just said it might not have been that
big a deal and then there might be
certain laws well you can carry him on a
job like this on a farm on private
property maybe they could do something
like that you know you can handle a
firearm I don't know I don't really
think that I think in a lot of cases you
know if you're on private property and
it's some kind of a farm or a business I
don't think I don't think laws are real
or they don't think they really worry
about it much yeah
but what I was gonna say was that you
know not only that but he also had
everybody in this is polygamous for some
reason yeah you know your no judgment
yeah um but basically I mean he had two
husbands who I feel kinda dudes gay we
didn't you mention that well everybody
knows I didn't know that yeah but you
look at that dude you're like I don't
know any gay dude it looks like that man
every day every gay dude that we know
what that [ __ ] knows how to
dress he's got a good teacher this guy
looks like something off a WWE from back
in [ __ ] nineteen his music videos
guys yeah I just feel like his husband's
at least one of them kind of first
started hanging out with him because of
meth yeah I mean because he had meth so
yeah so I feel like it's not a good
situation
he's keeping 200 big cats tigers and
lions in his on his compound or whatever
and people are like paying to come see
them he has like other animals too we
have like alligators and all this other
kind of [ __ ] so but he has like a bunch
of people running around who aren't
really trained in this type in
veterinary medicine or you know handling
big animals and they're all on a bunch
of drugs yeah and they're running around
guns shooting at each other for fun
shooting at each other for fun it's just
it's a very it's a poor it's it's not an
ideal situation now let's put it that
way
man and it's just like crazy his [ __ ] is
the craziest but then they go into da
cantle bhagavad Duck it's all for crazy
who is essentially running what appears
to be a cult yeah yeah like in every
sense of it what every sense of the word
it's a cult it's a hand and a harem of
women which hey if they want it I don't
have a problem you don't mean it felt as
long as it's always good but the way
he's recruited and this is what I was
getting back to the horse business to
ever [ __ ] like this going on in the
horse business yeah if you have a barn
and a bunch of [ __ ] your trainer and
you got a bunch of [ __ ] horses you
can also collect a hare I'm a [ __ ]
young women you can't evidently does it
do it yeah I don't know if it's just the
Tigers luring the women or if he's got
some other [ __ ] going on I don't know
what especially girls that want to ride
they want know what they want they want
horses and [ __ ] they don't have any
money then you're gonna get snapped up
by a trainer right and I don't know what
it is these girls and these [ __ ]
horses I was raised around it so I
didn't have the fascination and being a
boy I didn't have the fascination of
riding on something big has a [ __ ]
four three foot [ __ ]
[Laughter]
there's something about these girl you
wonder why women are attracted with a
[ __ ] three-foot [ __ ] [ __ ] on
yeah there's no denying and I do feel
like a lot of young girls because I
remember you know being a divorce is
when I did have a change and a lot of
other girls my name is Hubert either
yeah like right when you're about ten or
eleven yeah then it's just it's just
something a woman so maybe I don't know
it's not really it seems like it's kind
of a different thing with the big cat
thing though because you can't really
ride them and you can't really I mean
but it's the same thing they're like a
big powerful animal now we got to you
and and you can like you know you can go
and pet them and stuff like that and
like you know this could kill me it's
like you know it's you know any kind of
like it's the allure of like being
dangerous and exotic and stuff like
that's like I can kind of see that but
pretty much like I said everyone in this
is insane
and I do feel like I mean the [ __ ] that
happened between Joe exotic and between
his rival Carroll Baskin this just goes
to show you whether or not she was bad
or not because there are some
allegations against her that haven't
been proven so I'm not gonna you know
say anything about that cuz I don't know
if they're true or not
a lot of people seem to think they are I
don't know I don't know what happened
but it just goes to show that even if
she was doing like half of the stuff
that he was like paranoid or that he
accused her of doing it really seems
like this is this is a thing where you
don't put all your [ __ ] on social media
because the fact that he had all of
these videos that he made all of these
yeah things that he made like that were
openly openly illegal openly [ __ ]
threatening yeah yeah that type of stuff
it's like that just seems like a really
dumb thing to do he was a low IQ dude
very low like you did wouldn't with
limited self control well and no
self-awareness no Subway's yeah um and
it does really didn't realize no he
didn't realize how things that he said
and did and showed in video how that
could be used against him what the [ __ ]
was he thinking and some of this stuff
it's like I can see like making a video
and saying something kind of dumb that
is like but but this was like a big this
was like I sustained
like over and over again
and it's like you should have known
better because it's like when something
you know ends up happening like later on
you know everybody's gonna know exactly
what [ __ ] everybody's gonna know you
were to go to sit in there [ __ ] and he's
sitting there basically making
terroristic threats over and over and
over again and each one of those threats
and some in the state of Florida pride
cares about five years you know doing it
on [ __ ] public access like on his web
TV show and like you like he thought
nothing of it that's what I'm saying
it's like he didn't really have any
self-awareness I'm like do you realize
how that's making you look and that if
some implication or the legal
implications of it's like you can't do
that yeah you can't like make videos and
post it on Facebook and say I'm gonna
[ __ ] you can't do that I'm gonna cut
this bitch's head off especially
nowadays it's like you might have been
able to get away with it back in the
[ __ ] 70s or 89 of my man aware that
he may be back then you probably
couldn't but like nowadays really you
can't because a terroristic threat it is
that's exactly what it is and I don't
think he saw it that way I just I just
think that they were all just kind of
like so aw shucks you know down-home
kind of like they didn't think anything
they did was a big deal yeah and I think
and it really got them in trouble I
believe in freedom of speech and [ __ ]
you know in the First Amendment but you
can't threaten to kill somebody to
murder them no you kids yeah I'm gonna
kill this [ __ ] no you can't do it and
he wasn't just saying it if he was
gunned down shoots nuts making videos
like it was just stupid stupid stupid
you shouldn't have never seen a lot of
course a lawyer will [ __ ] have a
field day with you in a court of law
with that [ __ ] yeah just dumb dumb ass
like I said there's just the way that
they acted like it was just no big yeah
yeah oh we're just talking
this is joke they're almost like making
a big [ __ ] joke about I'm like yeah
that's like not funny oh man I mean it's
like and it's no people so I was like
curving your free speech or nothing like
that it's like you just can't do put
yourself out there if she and here's
noting is that if you start making
terroristic threats to some person and
you don't ever plan on ever do anything
to that person somebody else can
overhear that and says I can do it I can
kill em bitching he'll get playing for
yeah and then
there do it you just you don't do it
don't do that's it yeah someone else
could see that and run with it
ah there's my opportunity yeah they'll
blame it on that dude right which might
you know who knows yeah
so you just that's just putting yourself
in or like a really really stupid
situation and like I said it just seems
like everyone in this is either stupid
or crazy or both or both um but that
said this is a really really
entertaining series because you just
will not believe I mean if you don't
know the particulars of the case and
stuff you will just not believe like the
[ __ ] batshit insane directions that
this goes in and it's just like [ __ ]
crazy like I said it's it's the kind of
thing where it's really entertaining and
you just can't believe some of the stuff
and it's like hilarious and ridiculous
and just outlandish and stuff but then
you also kind of feel bad because at the
end of the day like these poor animals
that are just like sitting there going
what about us yeah this is how this all
started and now that's just like all
about horrible people yeah
the Tigers looked well-fed and you know
that the cats lived well-fed they were
having a good time but they he had them
nearly 200 of them at one point yeah and
you know that's not cool yeah be around
some so many cats you can see a male
running around in circles and it just
that shit's dangerous what if those
things got out that's what I mean it's
like how far away did he live from like
his neighbor's yeah he just had what if
a whole pack of tigers yeah and he just
had them in chicken wire fences really
yeah it's like it looked like they could
get easily because there was like like
you said it's a whole bunch of them like
in some of the enclosures and you know
with the small crew that he had they
couldn't all you couldn't entertain all
those no that's what I was thinking we
have a gay man full of people working a
lot more like what the [ __ ] in here and
they're not really trained I mean none
of them were really trained it was cool
that he gave him a job and everything
like that but they didn't know anything
about it and the tiger put in the time
the big cat population just keeps
growing in there cuz they're
impregnating each other yeah and where
are the Cubs going you know maybe that's
yeah you know what like I said
everybody's [ __ ] yeah everything is
shady and it's just it's it's sad
and horrifying sad that that's where
most of your tiger that's where your
most your big cats are yeah and that's
kind of what they're like even though
the other places they showed were
physically a lot nicer yeah you know I
mean like the guy that had the harems it
looked like he was taking care of his
cats pretty damn well yeah he didn't
have as many that way yeah I think he
had a lot of money though he had a whole
neighborhood that he owned yeah for his
harem and yeah he's like yeah the other
wife lived there and I was there and
that one lose there and they're like
[ __ ] big three story that beautiful
houses he has a [ __ ] ton of money and
weird all that money come from
oh I'm sure that was another shady yeah
that's like I said everybody's inthis
like [ __ ] drug dealers or [ __ ]
selling cats or just there's all kinds
of it's all market [ __ ] yeah and he had
a big habitat and I don't think he had
200 cats though that's what I mean I
think he had significantly fewer yeah
and but and was he was running his gray
operation a little better but I'm just
assuming it's great with the way that
you know man I think that's a pretty
safe associated sounds I must see the
into that scene in its entirety like I
said it looked like all of them were
kind of doing great [ __ ] yeah I don't
think anybody in this oh yeah nobody I'm
sure everybody in this was doing at
least one Italy all that exotic exotic
animal I don't want to call it a
business because legally it's not a
business but that exotic animals scene
yeah is gray yeah but I think they
tolerate it I think the feds tolerate it
because they realized that that's where
most of those exotic animals are yeah
that's how they exist in today's world
yeah that without those guys it all
vanishes and all those animals along
they'd all be gone they'd all be gone so
it's kind of like a necessaries like
animals like maybe yeah and I think it's
only I think it's temporary eventually
they'll probably make it to where
they'll change laws to eventually these
animals have to evolve alongside man
somehow yeah ya know cuz you know no one
wants them to go because they don't
wanna go extinct so I don't know it's
admit they gave a good pet but they're
dangerous for you can't have apartments
you can't [ __ ] just let any old
person own one that's what I'm saying
this is just kind of like one of those
things where they never put up with it
for now yeah I'm
and then hopefully we can get to a stage
where only people that are like
professional and trained and stuff like
that can can have it and just don't like
don't let a bunch of Yahoo's it's just
like keep this but with like no
oversight or but they weren't arrested
that yahoo who had the 200 cats or we're
talking about what what happened to all
those cats and I mean they met all those
cats down that's what that's why
everything every decision about this
like shitty there's like no good outcome
and it's really really sad wait was kind
of holding all those cats hostage they
couldn't do anything against it because
I haven't really we would have to put
all those cats down yeah no one wants to
do that yeah I mean so it's it just
seems like like I said it just seems
like everything that's what I meant when
I what I meant that yes this is a
hilarious watch at a lot of the shit's
hilarious and crazy and everything but
it's also really kind of sad like in the
end so it kind of makes you feel like
man I shouldn't watch it like it makes
you feel dirty kind of yeah you know
what I mean
yeah he had him basically in his own
personal Zoo
yeah it's basically what it was yeah I
want to say like I was reading another
review of this earlier I can't remember
where I got it from but uh I love this
quote from the review it said I'd
describe it as like watching a
slow-motion car crash but only if that
car crashed into a jet plane and then
both tumbled into an oil tanker yeah
this is very much like that is you guys
Minoo if we haven't got you like hyped
for it like the last couple times we
talked about this yeah you really really
could have to watch this is amazing it's
the best thing alright you won't believe
it I mean seriously you won't believe
the crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] that happens in
this it's it's literally unbelievable
and what happens at the damn funeral
[ __ ] man I had that made me laugh the
moat I had to get up and walk around and
I was are queasy she was like what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah that was a face just
[ __ ] made me just [ __ ] blew a damn
eulogy [ __ ] I know I just couldn't
believe it what I was just sitting there
like wheezing like I loves it and like
just from disbelief I'm the only [ __ ]
crap is this real life yeah how is this
real life it's like a parallel dimension
Kamiya nice but yeah seriously it's on
Netflix if you haven't seen it I know
it's like it's so much hype and like all
the Revere's like this is the craziest
[ __ ] ever and you have to watch it you
do you gotta watch it it's it's [ __ ]
crazy
you
all right third movie we watched this
week just dropped on shudder yesterday
of the day before this is Daniel isn't
real yeah this is by the same company
that did color out of space and Mandy
yeah Spectre vision who was I it's a
Elijah Wood you know he is his
production company I'm among other
people so far everything from that
company looks [ __ ] awesome it really
does they have um you know they they
have like a really cool style yeah this
one is not so trippy but it definitely
has elements like you can tell that it
came from the same production company
yeah about this due to gets possessed by
a demon he was a kid he thought it was
his imaginary friend but man it's pretty
good that's a spoiler that's a spoiler
but that's a yes he didn't watch the
damn movie when I thought the movie
started slowly I was like at first but
then when it didn't picked up and and I
liked it a lot better you know about
like a half hour into it 20 minutes into
it yeah it had I guess it had a pretty
good beginning but then it just kind of
I don't know I just got better as it
went yeah a lot of it had to do with the
fact that it didn't have them Oh crazy
[ __ ] what's a gland
Nicholas Cage in it that dudes the [ __ ]
he'll get me to watch a movie
he's very polarizing you know a lot of
people I knew I loved Nicolas Cage I
think most people love it dudes [ __ ]
nuts because like I said he [ __ ]
commits man yeah
he'll just do crazy [ __ ] he doesn't care
but you know it was still a good movie
yeah this um this actually had its
premiere I think a year ago at South by
Southwest but they just released it to
digital and theaters I think in December
of last year so this is sort of a fairly
recent movie now I guess because it had
done the horror circuit so I've been
hearing about it because some people saw
it at the you know horror conventions
and were reviewing and stuff so I was
looking forward to seeing it so I was
really happy that um that shudder just
added it it was directed by Adam Egypt
Mortimer I think this is his second
movie he also did one called some kind
of hate which shudder also has but I
haven't watched
so now I'll definitely have to watch it
because I really liked this movie a lot
and it's based on a novel called in this
way I was saved by brian de lu who also
co-wrote the screenplay
with the director now the guy I don't
know if you know this and I did actually
didn't know this when I was watching it
like I saw it in the credits but I was
kind of like oh I wonder the guy that
plays Daniel as an adult yeah that is
patrick Schwarzenegger okay that is
Arnie's son it's okay the son of Anne
Maria Shriver yes mom so so yeah he's in
this like as the imaginary friend as a
grown-up so what what what we have here
is we have we start out with a character
named Luke as a kid and you see that he
has an imaginary friend who kind of
comes to him at a traumatic time I don't
want to ruin that yeah it's like that
early opening starts off with the bed it
does yeah so yeah and you think for a
second that this might be real of like a
real person but as the time goes on like
his mom like doesn't see him and all
this other kind of stuff but Daniel
becomes you know Luke's best friend now
the mom is played by Mary Stuart
Masterson as soon as I saw her I was
like hey it's what's-her-name from some
kind of wonderful the John Hughes movie
she was also in fried green tomatoes she
was in Benny and June and stuff like
that
I haven't seen her in a long time but
she was like immediately recognizable I
mean she's older now obviously but she
still looks enough like her character
back in the 80s that I immediately
recognized her so she's in this a little
bit and basically what happens is that
while they're both kids you can see that
Daniel is let's call it a bad influence
on Luke so he gets some they kind of
like trap him like in this dollhouse and
then many years go by you get Luke is in
college and he's having some problems
his mom who had some mental problems
they establish at the beginning the
mental problems have gotten worse and
worse she kind of has a sort of nervous
breakdown and they're hinting that it's
uh schizophrenia or something of that
nature and it's untreated because she
doesn't trust doctors so he kind of has
to go home and care for her at which
point
Daniel he releases Daniel from the
dollhouse again and you're thinking that
this really gave me a fight club meets
Jacob's Ladder meets they look like
people if I had to like compare it it's
like those three mashed up but it also
has like a lot of body horror in it it's
got good practical effect they are very
good and that's like there's some
visuals in this that are like real
trippy I like this company this company
you uses practical effects and CG but
they use it in the right way and they
use them intelligently you know I mean
they were oh yes CG - you know do color
and - foot you know I mean an intend to
have [ __ ] cool effects or to make
like small creatures that you have to do
CG and then they'll do CG overlaying on
top to enhance practical effect yeah but
because there's a practical effect at
the core it looks like it's really there
because it is it is so they do it right
that's how CGI should rise and I also
like to come - they make these are low
to mid budget movies but they're
punching way above their [ __ ] weight
and they kind of remind me of the old
horror movies like from beyond and you
know reanimate ER and all the classics
like they're they're the kind of movie
that you know or what's-his-name would
be in it's kind of a movie Jeffrey
Collins would have been in back in the
day but but they're done to a much
higher standard than what we had back in
the eighties and the nineties yeah
but it's it's that same underground vibe
to them if he asked me do you feel that
yeah and then definitely in this one
this one gave me a lift this was
actually um set in and shot in New York
City which is pretty unusual for a
low-budget movie like this because it's
very expensive to film in New York City
but they actually did shoot there and in
this one I would say the highlight of
this movie those practical effects and
swartz negra I didn't know that that was
so that was a yeah I saw his name in the
credits and I'm laying a strong point of
the movie really yeah
the acting is good throughout you know
everybody in it everybody in in this guy
but he was shining if you asked me yeah
you saw the two I didn't and that's not
anything had to do with his last name I
didn't know I didn't know until right
now
I was says he was really the best part
of the movie so I think he's got a
future ahead of him he's been in a
couple movies but I haven't seen a
minute this is the first thing I've seen
if you give this kid the right material
the right role in [ __ ] I'll call him a
kid you know 30-some kids yes thirty
something in the right role man he'd be
good he get he comes up he's a very
Patrick Bateman yeah role in this
because the thing about it and like I
said the thing that reminds me of Fight
Club - is that what you're getting is
that initially the imaginary friend
Daniel seems to be a positive influence
because he's kind of getting Luke to
come out of his shell he's getting him
to be more social he's getting him to
like take up hobbies and you know just
be more outgoing and stuff which is good
but then it gets to a point pretty
quickly where [ __ ] starts going sideways
because you already know from the
beginning like the [ __ ] that happened
with his mom at the beginning when he
was a kid that you know that Daniel is
not an entirely good influence and that
there's something you know more sinister
going on but initially you seem like it
seems like oh you know maybe this is
good he's kind of getting out of his
shell and he's taken up photography and
he's meeting women and he's doing all
this kind of stuff which she wasn't
really doing before because he was kind
of shy and he also has a thing where
he's kind of worried that he's inherited
his mother's mental illness which you
know that's understandable because
schizophrenia is heritable to some
degree so he's kind of had that going on
but then it just kind of gets worse and
worse and like I said it's they spend a
while and the thing that reminded me of
they look like people which was also
about a dude with schizophrenia that saw
demons and stuff that one was a lot more
low-key but also really creepy this one
is kind of like that in the sense that
you get the relationship between these
two characters and you initially maybe
think that it's the same person or that
Daniel is just like a representation of
his mental illness and he can control it
but then as the store
goes on you learned that that's you know
spoiler alert not the case of Tom
already spoiled it likes you hot to put
spoiler in the in the title just so
people will know yeah but yeah I think
that's teaser though
had I known it was a story about about a
demonic possession from the very
beginning I probably paid closer to
attention that first twenty minutes now
I want to see this thing again
it's definitely is something that is
gonna need a rewatch oh yeah because I
mean there's just such a great it's a
great idea
like I haven't read the novel but it's I
didn't really know that it was based on
novel until like after I saw it but it's
just the visuals are cool it's not like
I said it sounds trippy as you know
Mandy obviously there's not a lot of
movies that are strip is that or not
even as trippy as color out of space it
has moments like that um it's it lets
you know it's that same company yeah you
can tell and the soundscapes are similar
and like the most really good musical
choices I really liked the musical
choices that they made and I liked the
kind of like ambient sound scape was
really good
we have Colorado space on blu-ray I'm
glad I glad we got it I got to get Mandy
now might throw this one in on it too so
far man this company's given me you know
some quality energy yeah yeah then it's
giving me hope that's gonna be good a
confidence because you say I got some
confidence in this company now I'll
probably buy everything that they make
if it remains as good as it is now this
company claiming to me that they're
gonna make Dunwich or using the director
with the same director from cromoz
Colorado space because that guy's in
that dudes [ __ ] proved to me that he
can do a Lovecraft tale I'd like to see
Swartz [ __ ] in that in Dunwich horror
yeah imagine if they had him cast in
there yeah it'd be they'd be good that
would probably work out well yeah please
planned or I don't know maybe they
forgot a good role for him yeah maybe
the dudes a half goat man half shag ah
[ __ ] gnarly hotep [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah no you know I'm talking
about baby heat me arla yeah maybe he
could play the
I guess he was kind of the main
character and Dunwich or yeah the
half-human yeah definitely good yeah I
do I do tend to like like you said that
it does seem like a lot of horror movies
particularly well I mean mostly indie
ones are kind of going back to the roots
the roots like you know the 70s the 80s
that are kind of like going more in that
direction with pricey acts you know that
[ __ ] was always low-budget done right
yeah even Arnie's movies Terminator 1
predator 1 commando those were
low-budget movies yeah but they're
awesome yeah they relat relat or even
for the day they were kind of low-budget
movies but you wouldn't know by watching
them yeah and they stand you know that
they've stood the test of time
Terminator 1 didn't cost much to make
yeah I definitely feel like if you have
a good idea you have good actors you
have people who really care about how
the movie comes out um you don't need a
lot of money and in fact sometimes I
think too much money is a detriment
that's what I was thinking because
corruption gets involved well and it's
easy to like lean on easy solutions or
like you know crowd-pleasing type stuff
too much CGI too much other he cooks in
the damn kitchen
everybody's hiring their brother-in-law
to [ __ ] do this effect in that
effective MO and everything's done by
committee and Julia wouldn't want it
you're not really gonna get you know the
best commando wasn't made that way
Terminator 1 predator 1 those are my
favorite movies of all times even a
[ __ ] Total Recall wasn't make that I
was an artist warts [ __ ] fan Jenny
knows I got all the blu-rays yeah except
True Lies and that's only on DVD but and
even even Maggie and aftermath I had
that to them I'm harmless warts a nagger
watcher you know I didn't know this was
his son but he was the high point of
this movie yeah like I say he comes off
very much like a Patrick Bateman sort of
which i think is you know what they were
shooting be more good with it yeah he
did really good but yeah this is um
really good like I said if you like
Jacob's Ladder it has like a similar
kind of trippy thing to that or Fight
Club or something like that but it's
almost kind of like it's psychological
horror but then there's body horror and
thriller elements also so it's like a
really sick
cessful crossover it seems to be getting
like really really good reviews and even
like I said when it first came out like
it all the conventions your festivals
like everybody that saw it that's why it
was like I was kind of hyped to see it
because they've been like a lot of
really good buzz about it and now like I
said I'm gonna have to see this guy's
other movie because I'm pretty sure
that's on shudder as well but if you
have shudder they just added this just a
couple of days ago and it is definitely
worth checking out if you are a fan of
any of the other movie in the gripe
about the movie is the pacing in that
first 20 minutes yeah off with a bang
and then it kind of slowed deck it was
good it slowed down a little bit and
then it kind of slung back down a little
bit more and that kind of lost a little
bit of interest for a few minutes and
then it then it came back yeah and you
know I have to see it again yeah this is
one I definitely want to give a rewash
tale because I think I missed some stuff
yeah you know what I mean it's one of
those ones that you kind of have to
watch it again if I like it I'll buy it
buy it on blu-ray yeah and I can I gotta
get Mandy on blu-ray
well yeah cuz I thought you already had
that to be honest yeah I thought I did
too but I don't think I have it yeah I
gotta go through the go through there
and look yeah you have so many you have
so these I don't really know which one
but yeah this is definitely if you have
shutter check it out it's a really good
definitely worth watching especially if
you like any of the other movies that I
mentioned like Fight Club or you know
Jacob's Ladder or anything like that
this is kind of like an evaluate for
Dunwich or ya know I really really hope
they [ __ ] to make that I also want to
see the mountains of madness yeah I
wanted to make that too yeah somebody
needs to make that yeah I've seen a
couple movies that were courts sort of
similar to that or like loosely based
like there was one called black
mountainside which I think might be on
TV for free and that kind of has a
similar premise a little bit imagine if
this country if this company did Call of
Cthulhu yeah see that big yeah we're
speculate I'd be like making King Kong
yeah yeah that definitely would be cool
right
yeah but yeah so check this one out
definitely worth watching
[Music]